richard's a weird dude he's always
calling people and going like gary said
and jason said like richard will call up
literally with the same question
how long can you keep like chicken
that's been out on a counter
for like a couple of days can you still
eat it or
how i've had been out on the counter for
a couple who knows
and then he goes do you know like like
we've had chicken in the refrigerator
you know raw chicken for a week and a
half is it still good
how many times do you have to call the
guys and ask them if you know
if the chicken is bad after it's been
out for four days i mean how many times
do you
i i'd like to get a second opinion if
i'm like but we
tested your iq you can retain
information you know that
the meat is bad i mean come on you know
what maybe it's from growing up like we
never wasted any part of any animal we
really eat like the head and everything
but why is this stuff laying around for
so long in your house
cook it up and and eat it well we'll
i'll lose stuff
in the back of the fridge that's just
you know i forgot about and i'll find it
one day and i'll be like oh i wonder if
this is still good
eggs from 1987. hmm wonder if that's
still good where's jason's number
oh one time my my parents sent me some
sausage through the mail
like a deer sausage and it got lost in
the mail it was
gone for like three weeks and it finally
showed up
and uh and i and then
[Laughter]
yeah well he doesn't even react to food
poisoning
anymore except for [ __ ] his pants
you know he doesn't even get a
stomachache he just shouldn't
and i don't yeah and i don't mind
[ __ ] my pants once in a while it
doesn't hurt
i like it i don't even clean it up i
just like walking around like this
given up telling him there's a problem
how long it is can you leave [ __ ] in
your pants
oh there's been times where i didn't
know i did and at the end of the day
i'll look at it and i'm like
how uh-oh do you not know you shake your
pants you have to feel something dude
i mean seriously i just think it's a
fart and then you realize it
like the time we did the diaper contest
i had no idea
that i had had that accident i farted
into the microphone and then we came
into the studio
and i you know looked in my diaper to
weigh it and i was like oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] my pants one last trip to the
bathroom
my parents literally said i was potty
trained by [ __ ] in the yard
like that's how i learned to uh
use the toilet was by pooping out in our
yard when i was a little kid
how does that teach you to use the
toilet i mean you're [ __ ] outdoors
on the well because i'd walk around
naked without a diaper and that's how i
learned to like poop without a diaper
oh like a dog in other words you're
allowed to [ __ ] outside just don't do it
in the house
that's right exactly i would go out in
the front yard and do it the neighbor
lady would call my parents
that [ __ ] by the mailbox did you have
like favorite spots you would go to to
[ __ ]
when you were a kid we had a sandbox and
my parents said i used to go
sometimes in the sandbox i would like a
cat
i'd make my duty sand castles